[Music]
this week we've got House of Drew
Midwest fries and drunken landing oh
yeah I also drew like basketball nope no
no is it drew leaks what is it
drew league d-league Deeley yep oh no
David Nelson well that's not what this
is about so this is about Justin
Bieber's new clothing line called house
of Drew yo I saw his middle name one
photo I look like trash does it look
homeless I can oh it's the unisex
homeless line I saw it you basically
dress up as a cardboard box and that's
it that sounds cool so the reason why
are we talking about it though is
because fans are pissed about the price
don't buy it well the reason why it's
our age is because the first thing like
from the first launch they were selling
a pair of hotel slippers that were just
$4.99 but then now that they have all
these other items its price between a
hundred and twenty eight dollars to one
hundred and forty eight dollars it's
forty eight dollars for a t-shirt $98
for a hoodie everyone's so mad at
everything people are like where's the
section for the broke people but that's
from this broke don't buy anything new
piece [ __ ] get hotel slippers
from Best Western and [ __ ] and [ __ ]
sell that online show you I love how
your mind works like he went and he
stole them from businesses well these
are not cute they're not but it's not
meant for you if you can't afford it
they look like they just stole from
China Tom mark well first of all number
one they call the local zone so this is
the rest of it that's all ritz-carlton
it does look like a bite from Chinatown
markets sorry to say and I love Biebs
but they look like me it all came from a
mental ward here's here's my thing
though they look like they work at Home
Depot doesn't [ __ ] matter because
number one if you're seeing a $48.00
t-shirts expensive you've supreme
wearing [ __ ] like get the [ __ ] out of
here dude a [ __ ] bait shirt a supreme
shirt they're all [ __ ] hundred to 150
and they're blanks bro yeah and they're
[ __ ] gilben t-shirts what the [ __ ]
are you talking about dude they're not
even custom so the supreme in street
wear oh yes he does about this Justin
Bieber his whole family's wears that
[ __ ] they all wear [ __ ] supreme all
those [ __ ] little high piece [ __ ]
doesn't make sense then if they're into
that [ __ ] then why are they complaining
about the price well that's what I'm
saying it doesn't make it to complain
about everything I handle people
complain about like things that aren't
necessary to life and they can't afford
it like I understand if you can't afford
food and [ __ ] but this [ __ ] this is not
a necessity necessity this is a luxury
how old are they like 15 cuz I
understand I can't get my older now no
but even if they are 15 plus 15 and now
15 are way different dude like these 15
year olds spend money on [ __ ] no your
kids we would just scrounge around for
just blank long T's and [ __ ] whatever
like dick is [ __ ] oh yeah they don't
wear that [ __ ] anymore these kids are
[ __ ] flyest [ __ ] they drop money a
lot of my money went to ecstasy know
what I was wearing it's 17 different
colors of save money on a t-shirt it's
like some corduroy pants color boys
coming but how much is it yeah it's
coming back yeah it's one hundred forty
eight dollars that's not bad that's not
bad at all like I'm not saying well
first of all it is that's on the pricier
end but there are pants that are that
price
yeah that's pricier than diesel yeah
it's not like some outrageous [ __ ] I
thought it was like 300 400 bucks or
something how much is Jesus play dude
easy like any kind of like Kanye she
remember when we were in Japan it was
that one store that we went that was
just stocked full of all Kanye's [ __ ]
there was like a trench coat that was
like three grand
hmm yeah so I was thinking it was on the
line of that but I'm not gonna complain
that I can't afford it and then write a
letter to Kanye's team and be like yo
that's not fair I can't afford this it's
like [ __ ] Wall you're not the market
worth
I feel like Justin Bieber should be
allowed to put out whatever his brain
wants to put out yeah and if it cost
that much money to make then that's how
much it's supposed to be but you can't
complain you know it's like him coming
out with like a fine dining restaurant
and you're like oh how come these things
are so expensive it's cuz it's in his
brain he's creating a fine dining
restaurant
I don't put like this I never defend
bieber dude I think you trash this guy
consistent I always defend him all the
time and even then like for this like
number one 100% understand this is on
the higher end of like price sheet for
sure it is expensive I'm not saying it's
not cheap but I thought it was gonna be
on some outrageous [ __ ] dude yeah like
on some outrageous tip this is not
outrageous it's expensive but it's not
like he's trying to gouge the kanye [ __ ]
is ridiculous
yeah you know what I mean like he has
like a sweater with 7,000 holes
yep and then his [ __ ] there thousand
dollars so are they mad cuz they're like
oh I wanted but it's too expensive is
that weather man oh yeah everyone is mad
I know but the ones that aren't mad are
they mainly is that what it is it's like
oh man I want those clothes but there's
Justin Bieber merch right and that's
cheap at the concerts and stuff it's
like twenty thirty dollars well I see
you even merch is not cheap they're like
30 40 bucks purchase actually more
expense I try to buy a khabib and Connor
sure and that's was fifty bucks yeah so
why don't you do what most [ __ ] Tina
teenagers did is get a part-time [ __ ]
job and in one whole damn mug you could
buy those pair of pants yeah or if your
white kid just wait to your parents
sleep is still out of the wallet like no
one white kids do mm-hmm I heard that's
what you guys do I think I'm more I'm
more uh that he'd copy like another
streetwear brand versus the actual price
wash type in Chinatown market so like
it's a their logo is the happy face and
so like I would think with his creative
team they should be able to come out
some really cool stuff but it just looks
like parodied another company oh yeah
[Music]
yeah it is he's just put the word drew
on it you can't really but that's like
that's a really a big upcoming
streetwear brand right now and I just
look like a market why whether they're
big the outrage about how [ __ ] wack
it is yeah you know which makes sense
but then you know like all that stuff is
perspective if you could wear a shirt
that just in a red box that says supreme
then what's that what's the difference
between that and a smiley
face right I glad that it's expensive
you made like the logo they want to show
it all true but maybe people can also
let's give them some benefit now here
maybe they're pissed cause they're like
who do you think you are you're not a
fashion person at least with Kanye right
like he's been known to be a trendsetter
he has like shifted the way like rappers
were perceived in terms of the the way
the dress you know because he was the
first one to come out of hell a preppy
and [ __ ] a trendsetter inception so in
that regard people are like are I will
get if Kanye that pass because he has
been shown to be like something in the
in this world of fashion whereas Bieber
has never been looked at as someone
that's well to that sense to them then
[ __ ] Drake - and his OB oh [ __ ] [ __ ] all
of them
Drake Drake wasn't a trendsetter Drake's
the Drayson like one of those fall over
long fight no no one gave a [ __ ] about
him yeah I like this is happening though
because being complaining and outrageous
but [ __ ] y'all I'm sorry I like mine
looks pretty clean but when people buy
this [ __ ] it tells me who the [ __ ]
dumbasses are so it helps me
there you go so I don't have to I was
like oh you're wearing that new Bieber
like okay cool cool right I know who you
are
see ya see ya cuz if you have options to
like if you just want a piece of Justin
Bieber's like memorabilia
yeah but then again you're right like
the [ __ ] concert shit's how expensive
it's way more than they're really
expensive you know how much I paid for
the khabib hat $80 I needed to have it I
needed to have it before the fight and
now it's just sitting in our room but it
looks cool I'm aware I'm Jay King we're
gonna make poor rules
I spent a hundred and thirty dollars
just to support those guys in that fight
I'm guilty of that too but I just the
Bieber's making clothes for people like
Bart that's the consumer what it is
right there alright next story so you
guys have heard what the Midwest I've
heard of it I've heard of this
mysterious place I think it exists yeah
so you know it exists right yeah alright
so there's a mama dead this Polar Plunge
right now that so it's making a Midwest
colder than Antarctica whoa
you disrespect minion appellations you
said [ __ ] minute I didn't see that yeah
you possum yeah yeah you [ __ ] them yeah
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
but yeah looking at an article
oh wow what's happened holder there damn
it's summertime and the world's coming
to an end real soon
or sooner than we thought yeah when I
was there it was 29 degrees not negative
29 right mm-hmm
so this is this week right now can you
give me some perspective here like it's
that cold is it like if I turn on the
water faucet as soon as it like starts
coming out it turns into ice like is it
that's how the video today this girl
went out with her hair what and it stuck
straight up like March [ __ ] Ice
Age happening man no just the ocean no
it's a road oh [ __ ]
that's frost over it did the animals die
I know with you they have a report on
eight deaths imagine the whole time
people-people ah [ __ ] that I'm talking
about the moose
I don't know how do all those people I
think the Meese are finding the meats is
all like like they know what happened
did you see all the cars freeze they had
to set the railroad on fire
winter is coming all the ice so the
Train can actually go through and it can
shift all the [ __ ] dude white walkers
are coming dude white Walker yeah we
were in were we Minnesota Minnesota it
was negative 12 to negative 15 degrees
when we were here I was very close so we
know what that feels like - this dude is
frozen right he's only been outside for
three seconds it's a video we're
watching Wow beautiful though what a
great photo op devastating look at part
of me really wants to call her that is
scary
what does that Manman what oh not really
not really - this boy it's like 60 over
here yeah and I already put on the light
cardigan that was really frustrating g7
right now currently and I have a [ __ ]
bomber jacket right we don't like
[ __ ] compared to these people oh [ __ ]
yeah I'm a big [ __ ] anything under
sorry about leaving the house would die
I'm not trying to be a polar bear but
when it was 29 degrees though at the
minute it fell pretty good like when air
is cold doesn't it feel fresh to you if
you're directly really dude this was
Barta he'd still meet you out there
eating an ice-cream bar remember what we
were Japan in a couple years ago and
that felt awesome yeah what was the
temperature there cold cuz I think the
coldest I've ever been is like now it's
kind of warm actually 30 degrees I think
has been the coldest I've ever felt
maybe it wasn't that cold agrees that's
it yeah I thought five well in Missouri
I think like when it's in the 20s if
you're not wearing gloves you could feel
that [ __ ] away
yeah I remember that when we took our
gloves off to use our phone that's some
yeah well then you walk so much in Japan
that you don't get the cold that much
mm-hmm I am making a 40 something what
do you I kind of want to go there just
to feel it but be able to run inside of
a building you did feel it it was
negative 12 negative 15 or 40 negative
44 48 in Fargo I don't think it's
negative for it was it below zero is
that what they're saying yeah yeah below
zero 40 below zero like they have to do
weird things out there that I've never
even heard of but have I got a car
battery that keeps your car warm
overnight so doesn't so doesn't frog
yeah yeah when I got that Jeep I got the
engine block warmer for no [ __ ]
reason I'm in California Oh Lord and it
was tossed high just because it's it was
an extra $300 that's adult dog [ __ ]
Nobita and I got that [ __ ] and it's
supposed to heat up your engine that's
time I have a frost option in my car
that you could drive in like frosty
roads aren't else has it - but we'll
never use it
we're like you also it also tells you
like to prep for it so it'll turn on
your car like an hour before it's
holding everything else you got a big
bear I bought tire the chain thingy yeah
it's not only for snow though you could
be like for mud too in case I get stuck
but I just have it in my car forever
which I'll never use entertainer's
Nikola Tesla I bought it when I have a
civic huh Oh for this event yeah beer I
won't fit on the Tesla no the tire
specific tires are very big - on the
Tesla I don't even look at it before the
Honda when I bought it [ __ ] they're all
different sizes
she's got it for months you've never
needed it right yeah there's all
different size it goes by the diameter
of the entire tire there's like a sock
in general if you're going off-roading
on a Civic you've done something really
wrong
funny what we were all gonna go to the
Big Bear oh okay okay knowing there I
don't know if I need it but yeah I
didn't even know I think it said
universal fit no there's there's no
there's not you know one size fit all I
wonder if they can hear the Lightning
right now guys outside all right
next story I'm scared right now it's our
last story please give a [ __ ] we die at
least we die together that's why I'm
afraid don't let me distract it's gonna
hit this building before it hits us and
it's just gonna go all around it we're
fine
we have a force field around yeah and
it's not just ones at the back to that
for today G - is 44 year-old British man
what's that for so you could breathe
better by your elbow the shoulders Julia
Child sure yeah all right let me tell
you this last does this get stuck when
you'd move it no what do you mean the my
knees are back man cold shoulders are
cut out like it let me find a the
console is a 90s thing mmm-hmm Selena
we're stopping
I like those shirts that I mean not the
shirts but then the what do you call it
when it's like this it's Mexican
shoulders oh the ones that are here yeah
it's not Mexican you stooge no Mexican
girls wear - you know what the flag
early but traditionally worried it
wasn't invented fashion yeah yeah
shoulders bite no chief I know what you
mean yeah yeah we all know what you mean
but the fact no you did it that's why
you're like it's the basic game okay you
knew exactly what I was talking about
yes ma'am we only what is that that'll
spent a weekend
that's it you telling me we're Mexican
waitresses don't [ __ ] wear that [ __ ]
when they serve tacos the big dude
dude let me del taco boy going right now
they're worried you gotta go to a fancy
Mexican restaurant they're wearing that
[ __ ] alright the reason why I brought
that up is why is it here in that little
different style cuz then they also like
the tube top yeah oh yeah that reminds
me of that tank anyway band for the
titties alright continue so there was
this 44 year old British man who was
flying from Calgary Alberta to London oh
you suck you're from London blonde um he
got on the plane and he was so drunk and
unruly that the flights had to turn
around or land back the worst people so
a judge has ordered this man to pay more
than $21,000 to WestJet oh sure that's
how much fuel they had to burn come back
this is the route with you up in the air
for like scooby-dee this is what they
had to burn yeah they had to bring this
much fuel in order to land it you have
to burn a certain melt away yeah maybe
it's too heavy
probably uh communicating with the air
traffic controller hey is there enough
airspace for me no I just wait another
ten minutes if I just gotta keep
circling around yeah they wouldn't
expect no yeah they had to dump 20,000
pounds of fuel in order to land safely
so it was too heavy for that oh I always
thought it was tight when those two
planes have to like connect their
uncircumsized tips so they can develop
feel than they're in the air you know
fighter jets they're like oh they finish
like blasting the [ __ ] out of someplace
oh [ __ ] I'm running out of gas and then
like a big ol like bubble okay people
come into those
I did not know that either like a wig
it's crazy - could they have to be so
perfect and it starts dropping it's not
starting like you didn't know you guys
there's like oh there's a there's no
pictures we fly together I have to fly
together that's are they do they you
c-130s they look like a wiener comes out
and then and then it takes it from the
top
like meeting in pics it from the top
take it girl what that looks corny
that's it let me see let me see that one
better picture better pictures I see oh
there's nothing that's connected a
little dingleberry yeah it's sucking on
his dick that's pretty cool because of
this drunk man they're saying that
WestJet's total losses could be more
than two hundred thousand dollars which
include both the cost of the fuel and
compensation for other passengers on the
flights
how inouye the prosecution really
originally requested $65,000 restitution
but that's amazing reportedly did not
want to bankrupt this man so I do their
ordinate screaming 20,000 why was he so
unruly what was he doing drunk he got on
drunk yeah if I was on that plane I'd be
[ __ ] pissed
hell yeah yeah have you guys ever done
with really bad John people no no not on
the plane now on plane I'm Arlene but
like in general no dude I just don't he
was David [ __ ] Bupa ass people look
drunk like he looks like a drunk
celebrity that fell down from the top
and [ __ ] like he's like he's like it's
like bad years are coming it looks like
a seat on the plane I don't know they
just they just report drunken him he
could've been just talking [ __ ] to
everyone
I really hate people don't know how to
act in public dude yeah I really hate it
I only like happy drunk he's probably
back in the fact he looked like he looks
like he's studied for a [ __ ] week all
from startup and now he's like so sad
and he's [ __ ] doing heroin and [ __ ]
he needs to go to rehab
[Music]